ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the
Board of Trustees and the members of the
Academy I now present you with the tenth
president of Carnegie University dr.
Farnum Jahan Ian
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you very much
Wow chairman roar
trustees faculty colleagues students
staff alumni and honored guests good
morning and thank you it's a great honor
and a truly humbling experience to stand
here as the tenth president of Carnegie
Mellon University I hereby accept the
symbols the Office of the President and
all of the responsibilities pertaining
thereto
it brings me great joy to celebrate this
occasion with my family especially my
wife Tris and my children Daniel Thomas
and Sarah who have always been who have
always been my greatest blessing I am so
touched by the presence of friends
former students colleagues and
collaborators who have traveled from
across the country to be here I also
want to acknowledge community partners
and civic leaders from the Pittsburgh
region who are showing their support for
this University today and every day and
I would especially like to thank my dear
friends marlene Berman Keith block and
Martha Pollack for day kind and
thoughtful words this morning Martha
I've been following your footsteps what
you didn't tell them is that you were my
department head and my Provost I'm boss
for many many years
I don't know what you're planning to do
next I'm pretty happy to be here so
don't do anything else
[Applause]
today's ceremony is a celebration
steeped in tradition the singing of our
national anthem our academic regalia the
iconic sound of bagpipes these rituals
remind us that at this moment is not
about the beginning of my journey as
president rather this ceremony
celebrates our storied history as a
community of scholar in a nation driven
by learning and discovery CMU is
relatively a young University we've come
so far in such a short time and our
accomplishments would have not been
possible without the leadership of my
predecessors I specially want to
acknowledge and thank president emeritus
Jerry Cohen and past Bravo's
and past Provost mark Hamlet
for there
for their enduring commitment to this
University we are so grateful to you for
everything you have done for Carnegie
Mellon mark and Jerry of course great
leaders are inspired by an extraordinary
community as Mark and Jerry can attest
countless faculty staff alumni and
partners helped to build a foundation of
excellence CMU enjoys today I am
grateful to all the men and women who
have guided this university since its
founding and who will secure its future
in particular I wish to recognize the
members of Carnegie Mellon's board of
trustees who are distorts of this
institution I am so grateful for their
trust they have placed in me trustees
would you please stand to be recognized
Carnegie Mellon trustees
please
I would also like to acknowledge and
thank the university deans vice provost
and executive management team my
co-conspirators who do so much to
advance CMU every day with the
university leadership team please stand
to be recognized
like many of us here I left home as a
teenager to pursue an education as I
prepared for my journey from Iran to
Texas I remember asking my mother to
help me pack
she said pack light
because whatever you need you will find
there pack light because whatever you
need you will find there and so as I
left home with little more than a sense
of optimism and a desire to make the
most of the incredible opportunities
that only an education in the United
States could provide I've carried my
mother's words with me over these many
years I think her advice may have been
based on the hope that I would return
home once the initial excitement wore
off but I was pretty stubborn in fact I
got my tenacity from her along with a
work ethic instilled in me by my father
my siblings were here can attest to that
but looking back perhaps my mother was
hinting at the knowledge I would
accumulate in the journey ahead as a
teacher and advisor I came to understand
the incredible power of Education to
change lives as a researcher mentor
entrepreneur I observed the potential of
a single idea to launch a new enterprise
or disrupt an entire industry and during
my time in public service in Washington
DC
I saw how these ideas had the ideas
emerging from higher education serve as
serve as a foundation of our success as
a nation my 30-year career ultimately
led me here to this city and this
university this community our community
embodies all of my most fir
prevent beliefs and my greatest passions
every day at CMU I am inspired by you
here the world's most ambitious students
collaborate at the edges and
intersection of diverse fields and go on
to change the world as alumni here
faculty leave an indelible mark on
society through their scholarship here
professionals and dedicated staff create
an environment that support our shared
success these are the people and the
ideals that set CMU apart from the very
beginning when Andrew Carnegie founded
the Carnegie technical schools to
educate the sons and daughters of
factory workers in 1900 only it's an
evolution this institution would house
two great learning environments the
College of Engineering and the College
of Fine Arts you see right from the
start we were bringing together
creativity and industry our willingness
to take risks continued into the 20th
century when we became the first
degree-granting drama institution in the
United States and then when the Mellon
Institute of research founded by Richard
and Mel Andrew Mellon merged with
Carnegie Tech to create Carnegie Mellon
University and again when Newell Simon
perlis and Raj Reddy came to dominate
the emerging field of computer science
and establish artificial intelligence as
the next frontier in human progress
to paraphrase CS pioneer Grace Hopper
the most dangerous phrase in the English
language is we've always done it this
way so at a time when computers were
barely understood we were among the very
first to recognize the power of
computing and we made some big
in 1965 we established our department of
computer science in 1979 we founded the
first robotics Institute at the u.s.
university in 1984 we attracted funding
from the federal government to launch
the software engineering Institute and
in 1988 we announced the first college
in the world devoted solely to computer
science ours is still the model that
others follow
in the process we've created new fields
of inquiry such as machine learning
transition design and the science of
learning we magnified our societal
impact through technologies like
autonomous vehicles and additive
manufacturing and we did all of this
while also cleaning up at the Tonys the
Emmys and the Putnam competition
there's a lot to be gained by looking
back at our past we see who we are who
we've always been alumni from those
early years would certainly see
themselves in today's students
entrepreneurial creative collaborative
whip-smart and just a little bit quirky
well the past has left a bright trail
the future is arriving faster than
anyone could have predicted and you've
heard several speakers talk about that
our entire world is adapting to
unprecedented advances that are rapidly
transforming our economy our society and
our culture we must ask ourselves how
can higher education fit into this
dazzling future indeed our industry has
recently come under scrutiny this is not
a new phenomenon academic institutions
have often been seen as or criticized
rather as ivory towers but there is no
doubt that sustained investment in
research and education has fueled our
nation's broad prosperity since World
War two
[Applause]
universities exemplify our faith in the
power of Education to transcend social
economic and racial divides to reinforce
our role as pillars of progressive
society higher education must approach
our mission with renewed attention to
the unique demands of tomorrow at stake
is the ability of our society to retain
its fundamental commitment of democracy
truth equity and freedom of expression
[Applause]
at carnegie-mellon we have always
responded to challenges with trademark
fearlessness I'm reminded of the
leadership of dick sired who not only
pioneered a new model for business
education as Dean of our business school
but would later serve as one of the most
visionary CMU presidents more than 40
years ago he made bold but calculated
investments in the very areas that
define our leadership today these risks
were not always met with broad support
but that they paid off as a result CMU
grew from a small regional institution
to an international center of higher
education the time to be intentionally
bold is once again upon us we have a
singular opportunity to wield our
exceptional strength and make the next
big investments in our global leadership
let's consider together what society
needs most from academic institutions in
the context of our two core missions
research and education at CMU we advance
human knowledge through scholarly
research and forge new connections to
our humanity through the Arts
but the nature of research and
creativity is rapidly changing
increasingly becoming dependent on
people working across the boundaries of
stablished disciplines and on
computational data driven approaches
that are accelerating discovery and
innovation this is precisely where CMU
excels in fact we have cultivated a
distinct leadership where these two
areas intersect at the Nexus of
Technology and society through these
expertise we're enhancing the way we
live work and communicate and we're
shaping modern culture
through visionary art performance and
design CMU legend herb Simon once said
we're not observers of the future we're
actors our job is to design a
sustainable and acceptable world and
bring it about this remains true as true
today as when he said it more than 20
years ago what has also remained
constant is the tremendous
responsibility that comes with this
influence I was reminded of this last
year when I came across an editorial by
David Brooks in the New York Times which
reflected on Pittsburgh's Renaissance of
course our connection to this city is
one of our greatest strengths but this
article while acknowledging CMU's
positive impact also warned of a
so-called Carnegie Mellon layer of
prosperity that had not quite penetrated
working-class neighborhoods indeed we
are witnessing the disenfranchisement of
a growing segment of our population
people who just do not see themselves as
part of this new economy who can't even
imagine a pathway to entry while the
nature of this divide has been debated
by pundits on the left and on the right
this goes far beyond partisan politics
we all bear responsibility for ensuring
that the future we're building works for
everyone
if we succeed the United States will
become will continue to serve as a
shining example of prosperity and
democracy for the rest of the world here
lies the greatest obligation for
institutions of higher learning in the
modern era and a commitment that lies at
the heart of CMU's leadership even as we
break new ground in technology we must
work
mitigate any consequences that diminish
diminish human dignity and opportunity
that is why at CMU scientists and
engineers work together with
philosophers artists economists who will
shape what might be possible with
ethicists humanists and policy experts
who will guide our path and with the
behavioural scientist who will measure
the impact of our work on humanity
reinforcing our distinct is strength at
the Nexus of Technology and humanity
will be crucial to building an
extraordinary momentum in both research
and creativity and as president I am
committed to supporting this leadership
by investing in a diverse community of
faculty and researchers by doubling down
on our partnership beyond the borders of
our campus and by creating vibrant
living laboratories in communities
around the world this is the next
frontier for Carnegie Mellon and I
believe it will only deepen our societal
impact heading into the future
as much as we value or impact on of our
impact of our research and creativity we
are equally committed to our educational
mission and as a CMU parent the
responsibility of preparing the next
generation is deeply personal to me to
the CMU students here and today here
today and also across various campuses
and our our campus watch parties you are
my most important motivation you're
spending your most formative years here
from what I remember from my own college
experience you're undoubtedly forming
lifelong friendships you know many of my
best friends from college are still my
best friends today the foundation you
built here will sustain you as you enter
a world defined by continuous disruption
according to a recent study about
two-thirds of jobs that you will hold
throughout your lives
do not even exist this reality has
dramatic and immediate implications for
the kind of education you deserve today
throughout our history every period of
significant technological change has
been met with a corresponding wave of
innovation in education I'm here to tell
you that right now we are at the dawn of
the next major transformation in
education and Carnegie Mellon will be at
the forefront of these changes from
curriculum to pedagogy to structure and
organization we are reimagining our
education with your futures in mind
we're breaking down disciplinary silos
and launching cross-cutting programs
that better serve your interests and
society's needs programs like behavioral
economics neuroscience and id8
we're embedding continuing
learning in these skills that will only
increase in demand as automation
reshapes the future work skills like
communication critical thinking and
entrepreneurship we're investing in
infrastructure doubt supports the new
ways that students learn and collaborate
spaces like pepper quad and Scott Hall
we're utilizing our expertise in the
science of learning to develop a
personalized model of education focused
on how each of you learns best every day
we work to build and sustain a community
that's inclusive equitable nurturing for
both graduate and undergraduate students
a place where diverse perspectives can
come together in a culture of civil
discourse to our students thank you for
entrusting us with this most important
chapter in your lives you will always be
at the heart of my presidency as we
consider
as we considered aspirations that unite
this global community philanthropy must
continue to catalyze and support our
forward momentum in fact this university
was founded by an act of philanthropy at
this pivotal moment I am delighted today
to announce two extraordinary new
commitments that will provide critical
resources to Carnegie Mellon in recent
years Carnegie Mellon has been making
significant investments for our College
of Engineering including a
state-of-the-art maker ecosystem that
serves the entire campus today I'm
pleased to announce that the Allegheny
Foundation has committed a 30 million
dollar lead grant toward the
transformation of Scafe Hall into a
modern new home for our mechanical
engineering department
this grant the largest in the history of
Allegheny foundation will enable us to
bring our total infrastructure
investments in engineering or the last
decade to more than a quarter billion
dollars but this commitment CMU will be
better able to compete for betters best
students and faculty driving Pittsburgh
reputation as a hub for innovation we're
joined today by Matt Grohl president and
chairman of Allegheny foundation please
join me join me in thanking Allegheny
foundation for their generosity to
Carnegie Mellon Matt please stand to be
recognized
at a time when college education has
never been more important many
prospective students and middle-class
families feel as though they're simply
priced out of education that they may
need for the future this is why CMU has
made growing our endowment for
scholarship fellowships and financial
aid one of our most important strategic
priorities today I'm pleased to announce
that CMU trustee Todd Johnson and his
wife Cindy have committed fifty million
dollars to create an endowment to
support undergraduate scholarship and
student success
[Applause]
you know um I made the announcement a
couple of times yesterday and I said
this last night every time I'm making
this announcement when I get to the word
student I choke up that's why we're here
Todd and Cindy will you stand please to
be recognized
well I lost my place boy I didn't
realize this speech was this long I know
that tell me about it well back to the
place that I lost track of time
this support were will greatly expand
our ability to ensure that a Carnegie
Mellon education is within the reach of
all talented students this gift the
largest toward scholarship support in
Carnegie Mellon's history was inspired
by Todd's own path to success here at
CMU and the fellowship that funded his
education please once again join me in
thanking and congratulating the Johnsons
for their generosity and commitment to
our students Todd and Cindy we are so
grateful to you for your generosity
I hope you packed a good lunch this is a
long speech
my fellow Tartans whether you're in
Pittsburgh Silicon Valley Australia
Rwanda or Qatar I hope you are as
excited as I am about the future of
Carnegie Mellon University to be part of
CMU at this moment is to be at the cusp
of the next great phase of societal and
human development if we continue doing
what we do today we'll maintain momentum
and continue to be a great University
but if we are very intentional if we are
unapologetically bold and if we are
committed to taking risks I am confident
that we will position ourselves among
the top tier institutions in the world a
place that's known for the writing the
story of this century an institution
dedicated to anticipating and solving
the most pressing challenges facing
humanity through creative inquiry
through scientific discovery through the
impact of technology and through a
transformative education that changes
lives as we embark on this exhilarating
future together we do so as a community
bond to bound together by a set of core
values that serve as our foundation
integrity knowledge compassion respect
the great scientist Albert Einstein
understood this fundamental connection
between excellence and human values in
1950 he wrote only morality in our
actions can give beauty and dignity to
life
to make this a living force and bring it
to clear consciousness is perhaps the
foremost task of education Andrew
Carnegie put it a little bit more simply
my heart is in the work each one of us
has a role to play in bringing beauty
and dignity to our mission through the
impact we make on society the leaders we
develop and the opportunities we create
for others I am I feel privileged to
work with such outstanding partners and
I look forward to all that we will
achieve together thank you very much
[Applause]